friendly reminder that if you didn't see
on Twitter my kitchen is currently being
renovated five days a week from 8 a.m.
to 6 p.m. my house sounds like this
so unless I film in the middle of the
night or on weekends a few of my new
release reviews will be in the format of
my analysis videos since I can record
the audio at my office instead to be
honest this has always been my personal
favorite format to work in anyway
because it allows me to write my reviews
fully and make my points concise and
comprehensive without trying to develop
a review off-the-cuff I'm always trying
to improve this channel and I'm using
this kitchen renovation as an excuse to
challenge myself to create better
content so on with the review ready
player one was directed by Steven
Spielberg based off the best-selling
novel from Ernest Cline who co-wrote the
script with Zack pen it takes place in
the future of Columbus Ohio we follow
Wade Watts a wide-eyed youth who prefers
to spend his days in the oasis a virtual
reality universe created by a recently
deceased genius who left behind a
challenge to although asus users find
three keys that lead to a golden egg an
official ownership of the Oasis
Spielberg's film differs considerably
from the book shifting segments around
and in many cases adding segments not
even present in the novel but just as
Jurassic Park the film contrasted with
Michael Crichton's book the attempt to
compress Klein's sprawling story is
mostly successful although its bulky
length of 2 hours and 20 minutes is
evident during the occasionally bloated
third act we're ready player one excels
is its dazzling action sequences no one
Helm's a chase scene like Spielberg no
one few directors have mastered scene
blocking like him either he shifts
massive hordes of characters vehicles
and weaponry in and out of frame
seemingly melding multiple shots into
one one early race sequence is classic
Spielberg breathless and lightning fast
utilizing sound effects without a hint
of music the technical mastery on
display lingers long after the film ends
it's unfortunate though that the
characters don't have as much staying
power as the awe-inspiring visuals
Wade's turbulent home life is explored
in a few brief scenes he lives with his
aunt and an abusive boyfriend and in a
handful of moments it's made clear that
he lives in an unsettled dysfunctional
household but the characterization
beyond these sparse interactions is weak
at best virtually non-existent at worst
when Wade meets an intriguing girl named
artemus in the oasis he develops deep
personal feelings for her within moments
which was a bit jarring in defense of
this though ready player one is also an
exploration of reclusive youth culture
today the Internet has given people the
freedom to express some of their deepest
emotions under the guise of a pseudonym
or avatar account
Wade's avatar is parsable and he only
feels most comfortable when inhabiting
that digital body the other people he's
friends with in the Oasis also used
their avatars to reach out and be more
outgoing versions of their actual cells
hiding their own inner trauma or
hindrances behind a virtual face in a
more traditional world a burgeoning
relationship like the one between
Parsifal and Artemis would be considered
rushed but in ready player one it reads
as a cry for help from wait languishing
in his own personal hell in the real
world wanting to escape into infatuation
in the Oasis gratefully though under
Spielberg's surehand both ty Sheridan
and Olivia Cooke deliver excellent
performances although the standout here
is Cooke whose stoic badassery and
closeted sensitivity gets revealed in
key moments striking a fine balance
between coarse and delicate Ben
Mendelsohn relishes his role as the
arrogant and villainous leader of ioi
and he chews up every scene in regards
to the music Spielberg's frequent
collaborator John Williams had to step
down from this film due to his work on
the post and the choice to hire Alan
Silvestri instead was made who composes
one of his most boisterous and
exhilarating scores in years it bursts
through the speakers like some of his
best work from the 80s and is a major
plus for the film a major concern on my
mind going in was the pop-culture
references the trailers honestly did not
impress me and I feared the movie would
rely simply on a vast amount of oh I
understood that reference or I remember
that scenes for some this will be a real
problem because undoubtedly ready player
one is one of the nerdiest movies ever
made it's littered with characters we've
loved in other things and is filled to
the brim with moments that recall
nostalgia from 80s movies and video
games the thing is we communicates a
Hollywood with our wallets that's how
they hear us critics and audiences loved
Deadpool wreck-it Ralph or Stephen
King's it
all littered with pop-culture references
what would you say is one of the most
popular current television shows
stranger things a show that's entire
foundation is built upon 80s nostalgia
from Hollywood's perspective the shows
and movies that we've popularized and
spent our hard-earned money on mean that
we've asked for a movie like this even
if we didn't realize it so do the
references bogged down the movie in a
few scenes yes for a nerd like me
there's definite joy and seeing anime
and video game characters I've always
loved on the big screen and I'd be lying
if I said I didn't frequently smile at
the sight of a beloved character or
vehicle but in the end some of the
references felt vapid and a little
hollow leaving me wanting for an
emotional connection that wasn't always
there
that being said seeing the bike from
Akira however was gratifying for a very
specific reason in the late 80s when
Akira was trying to gain a foothold in
America both George Lucas and Steven
Spielberg famously labelled the landmark
anime film as unmarketable how cathartic
that thirty years later that iconic
motorbike is spotlighted in Spielberg's
latest film with a world as sprawling as
ready player ones obviously some
exposition is required but it's
disappointing that the first 15 minutes
rely so heavily on narration there's a
lot of telling rather than showing it's
a tad frustrating because Wade will be
explaining the Oasis to us while walking
past people in their homes engaging in
their inner fantasies we see a young kid
who's a boxer and a woman who pole
dances these images are enough to convey
that people can be whatever they want to
be in the Oasis but oftentimes the film
dumbs down the expository dialogue
almost in an attempt to ensure that we
get it even though the discouraging lack
of character development and rampant
references can be a little pummeling to
the senses Spielberg's razor-sharp
command of stunning action sequences and
his unique sensibilities for sustained
aw are unmatched ready player one is
enjoyably diverting and speaks to the
nerd in all of us in some way shape or
form just as we often turn to video
games to help us escape from our
real-world problems Wade and his new
friends enter the Oasis to run away from
their harsh reality it's a relevant
message that
have been made better with more scrutiny
given to why Wade and his friends feel
as disenchanted with the real world as
they do I'm gonna give ready player one
a B also I noticed that quite a bit of
my film reporter and film critic friends
have joined the app Stardust tons of my
buddies are on there and now so am i I
hope you guys can follow me on Stardust
and see some of my thoughts too TV show
episodes and trailers I'm gonna be
posting that there and you can also
check out the reactions that I post on
Stardust and then send me your own
thoughts on said film or TV show or
trailer and I might be able to feature
one of your thoughts and one of my
videos down the line it'll be a fun way
for me to interact with my subscribers
more and hopefully give some of you guys
the spotlight on one of my videos as an
example here's me showing my
anticipation for a quiet place hey guys
thank you very much for following me
here on Stardust I'm excited to start
this new platform with you guys
I am super anticipated for John
Krasinski's film a quiet place I'm
hearing great things out of South by
Southwest please tag me if you have seen
it and let me know what you thought of
it or share your anticipation for it
with me and I will hopefully feature
your anticipation or your thoughts in an
upcoming video thanks guys see you soon
so give me a follow with the link in the
description below thank you so much as
always for watching guys more reviews
very soon including my review for Seven
Samurai which will be up this week or
this weekend for sure you guys are the
best thank you very much as always for
watching and if you like this you can
click right here and get stuck mine eyes
[Music]